le chef de bureau à québec est avec nous
pour nous aider à y voir plus clair
parce qu'il ya deux aspects là demain
sébastien joie alors sur la décision
d'affaires d'abord est ce que julie
snyder a raison de dire qu'elle est
punie parce que son principal client
d'affaires il son conjoint
alors oui et non dans la mesure où les
règles fiscales si on prend strictement
les règles fiscales
il n'y a pas de discrimination parce que
les règles fiscales en principe
s'applique à tout le monde n'importe qui
dans la situation du couple sinon à 2
péladeau n'aurait pas droit au crédit
d'impôt du gouvernement dans cette
situation le problème c'est que dans le
domaine culturel de la production
télévisuelle
il y a qu un cas et donc madame sneijder
est la seule à subir les contrecoups si
on veut de la politique du gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle lady
qui lie à discrimination indiqué les
punit le gouvernement argumente par
contre qu'il ya une façon de contourner
la difficulté c'est si madame sneijder
diversifier ses clients si elle faisait
de la production télévisuelle qu'il
vendait à d'autres que tva précités
viande n'était plus son client principal
elle pourrait à nouveau touché le crédit
d'impôt le problème ici aussi parce
qu'il y en a un c'est que ça prendrait
quelques années avant que madame
sneijder puisse de nouveau touché ce
crédit d'impôt quelques années de
diversification de clientèle sion il ya
l'autre aspect maintenant parce qu'on ne
peut pas ignorer le fait que quand même
son conjoint c'est pierre karl péladeau
est donc le chef du parti québécois et
ce cas là dedans dans cette sortie
aujourd'hui une stratégie politique
c'est certainement légitime de se
questionner parce que comme vous le
dites madame soleil la femme du chef du
parti québécois pierre cap et ado je
vous dirais pas que c'était une
stratégie orchestrée je vais constater
les conséquences la conséquence c'est
que madame sein d'une attaque le
gouvernement de philippe couillard et là
elles alimentent la dynamique de
confrontation entre le gouvernement et
monsieur péladeau dans laquelle on est
depuis plusieurs semaines alors il n'y a
peut-être pas de stratégie en tant que
tel mais la conséquence c'est
certainement que il ya de l'eau qui est
apportée au moulin si vous ajoutez que
le parti québécois avait pris une
décision pour donner le crédit d'impôt à
madame sneijder et que le parti libéral
le lui a retiré donc le moulin politique
a de quoi être alimenté pendant encore
plusieurs semaines
merci beaucoup comme toujours très
éclairant merci ses passes